oi eu sou mas agora faber tem 14 anos
sua criadora do diário de classe
acho que alguns devem conhecer mas daqui
a pouco vou explicar melhor o que é eu
só de florianópolis mora em
florianópolis na praia do santinho que
tem como título a praia mais limpa do
brasil e mergulha muito isso mas eu vim
aqui pra falar sobre o diário mesmo eu
vou explicar como surgiu a ideia tudo
que aconteceu eu tenho todo o primeiro
ano hoje mas eu fiz o ensino fundamental
todo na mesma escola e escola pública lá
no meu bairro e quando entrei na
primeira série a escola estava bem
novinha tinha dois anos e aí quando eu
cheguei na sétima e minha irmã estava
estudando uma escola particular porque
ela recebeu uma bolsa e eu fui conhecer
a escola e aí eu comecei a comparar a
escola dela com a minha que a escola
dela tinha tudo tentar dinho as portas
estavam inteiras tinha ventilador e eu
cheguei em casa conversei com a minha
outra irmã sobre isso e perguntei que
porque a gente paga imposto ea nossa
escola é assim né a gente tinha que ter
uma escola melhor do que uma escola
particular porque é nosso direito ea
minha irmã disse que tinha lido uma
matéria de uma menina escocesa marta tem
que tinha criado um blog para reclamar
dos meandros das escolas britânicas é
essa outra menina ali e aí ela falava
que chegava em casa com fome e eu decidi
criar uma fanpage só que no facebook
porque era onde eu sabia que tinha
milhares de pessoas conectadas ao mesmo
tempo então eu criei o diário de classe
de 11 de julho de 2012
depois de um mês mais ou menos que eu
criei
eu comecei a sair
eram três mil curtidas jornalistas
começaram a me procurar e eu passei a
ser reconhecido na rua
todo mundo falava comigo pensei que as
coisas estavam começando a mudar né
aí depois de 15 dias que os e na mídia
eles reformaram toda minha escola todos
os problemas que tinha denunciado eles
foram lá e consertaram e aí eu postava
alguma coisa em menos de uma semana eles
solucionava o problema e eu fiquei feliz
pensei que os alunos os professores vão
gostar também
só que foi bem difícil
os professores eles começaram a encontra
eles passavam nas turmas mais velha eu
estava na 7ª série
eles passavam nas oitavas séries dizendo
que o que estava fazendo era contra o
trabalho deles que num que não podia
fazer isso que os alunos mais velhos
eles tinham direito de me bater até
porque eles eram menores de idade e ele
podia fazer o que eles quiserem só que
eu não podia continuar com o diário de
classe
aí começaram a surgir as ameaças teve
essa senhora ea minha avó que em uma
noite eles jogaram pedras na minha casa
e atingiu ela e eu tava fiquei nervosa
não sabia o que fazer mas eu não pensava
em desistir porque quando chegava na
escola alguém falar alguma coisa chegado
em casa e ia dar os comentários de
pessoas que me apoiavam então era pra
mim continuar aqui eu estava fazendo
certo e que essas pessoas que encontra
era ciúmes pessoas me incentivando a
continuar
só que os meus pais também a uma
professora de português e fez bela
contra mim os meus pais estão sendo
processados a professora diretora foi
pra lá fez gol contra eles também tudo
isso aconteceu porque aí eu tentei
ajudar o ambiente de trabalho deles né
afinal não sou só eu que estudou a eles
também trabalham eu pensei que era uma
coisa boa mas eu não pensei em desistir
porque tinha o apoio dos meus pais e
tinha o apoio de
muitas pessoas muita gente e aí depois
de um tempo
outros alunos começaram a criar de horas
de classe também aí eles me mandavam por
um box a criei um diário de classe nos
eles também sofriam represálias os
diretores tinham alunos que estavam
sendo ameaçados serem expulsos da escola
isso é ruim mas alguns também
conseguiram melhorias e muitos
desistiram porque não agüentaram o mas
eu aprendi com isso que vale a pena
seguir nec e eu pensei que era só eu
queria mudar mas depois disso eu passei
a ser convidada a participar de vários
eventos e eu percebi que tem muitas
pessoas tipo você acessou os
palestrantes que estiveram aqui ainda
não está que eles também têm vontade de
mudar e eles também estão incomodados e
isso fez com que eu me deixasse de me
sentir sozinho né
e eu sempre usei a frase do roberto
marinho que é acreditamos nos sonhos e
construímos a realidade porque tinham
professores e até de universidades que
falavam que era um sonho que a educação
pública ela sempre foi assim e ela
sempre a seguir sendo assim e isso eu
tinha até pena dos alunos deles porque
não tem explicação isso né
agora hoje eu tenho uma ong ou ongs
adora fábrica que a gente tem como
objetivos das outras escolas porque eu
recebia de 7 a 10 mil pedidos de ajuda
de outros alunos que também estavam
incomodados e eles queriam que eu
ajudasse que eu fosse lá só que aí eu
não sabia como a gente criou uma ong tem
esse objetivo esses são alguns objetivos
que tem mas tem mais lá no site ea gente
quer agora a gente está trabalhando num
projeto que é aluno nota 10 que é um
projeto que vem da bahia e a gente
buscou criador desse projeto agente que
ela vai para florianópolis mas está
dando problema com a secretaria de
educação
o que eles não querem deixar a gente
falar com as escolas e mês que vem agora
dia 16 de maio vou lançar meu livro em
florianópolis provavelmente dia 5 de
maio não tem dia certo aqui em são paulo
e depois no rio de janeiro que o livro
conta toda a minha história antes do
diário e depois e o que tudo que eu
passei assim com um detalhe sobre sobre
isso
então agora eu só queria agradecer a
todos vocês ao pessoal do tre do tex
pelo convite e dá os parabéns para os
outros palestrantes também obrigada